baby backs  here's my power I spoke become yours for  you okay  [Music]  that's crazy right what are your  superpowers superpowers dude I don't  even know how to pee in this thing  [Music]  electricity manipulation  hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of  your finest beer please  [Music]  is Kathy Sparkle fingers no it's not  it's not money that's not my name chosen  one oh like a bad guy you normally did  the opposite of what a superhero is  supposed to do you're him  you're the hero  you're welcome for not getting robbed  I want you basically 15  [Music]  see that yeah you will let the computer  to bus and almost kill these people  and then I caught it and they tall  buildings in a single bound  you